[Music]
from the director of a hog I know him
again comes Will Smith's biggest mistake
since turning down the matrix after
Earth prepare for Shyamalan signature
slow pace and joyless tone but now with
ten times as much sci-fi mumbo-jumbo
detected graviton of operations in the
hall graviton build-up could be a
precursor to mass expansion mass
expansion is one milli the pull of our
own graviton weight could set the thing
off Oh God you guys really gonna make me
do this one okay get ready for the story
of a talented celebrity dad and there's
less talented bratty kid I am dedicated
how studied and consistently display
cars are becoming of a ranger sir who
takes on a challenge he's not ready for
and you think I'm a coward you're wrong
de whenever they got that idea
watch as Will Smith one of the world's
most charismatic actors plays a man with
no charisma what do you think you should
have done because worthy that is all
that matters names cypher Raige very
funny guys
what's his real name general sufferers
of the prom
mandus ah the race you've got to be
kidding me
watch as cypher Raige and his son khatai
rage dramatized what it's like to live
in the Smith household are you asking me
or telling me
but when father and son are forced to
bond disaster strikes as they crash on a
terrifying version of after Earth pull
of non threats like monkeys eagles
whales bugs snakes foliage and the gold
everything on this planet busy fall to
kill humans as it though because it
kinda looks like before earth to me so
take a knee and watch a movie of Will
Smith watching the movie of Jaden Smith
bum will be able to see everything that
you see in the most blatant example of
Hollywood nepotism since the third
generation of the Wayans brothers my son
black I like you but I think it's
something bad you like it but you think
it's something bad did someone actually
read this before they made it a movie do
you know what I can't do this this movie
is too dumb on too many levels I mean
why does everything on earth freeze at
night wouldn't that kill all the
greenery and the animals speaking of
animals why does that eagle atop jayden
is one of its young then commit Eagles
suicide to save him from the cold
it hasn't figured how to live in the
cold over the last thousand years of
being an eagle seriously we travel all
across the galaxy to stay on earth and
they didn't even make Earth cool we're
all the buildings the survivors anything
god this movie is so stupid
look I gotta get out of here it's just
not worth it you guys don't have to pay
me for this one
just call me next week for walking dead
that sucked that is correct
um but I don't think he's coming back
what should I do just read this what
does the Fox say
ring ding ding ding ding - ding franca
ding ding ding ding ding huh I have to
throw up